In one of your articles about deciding whether or not to do
Kibo, you talk about totally still, right?
That's an old article.
Isn't it actually wrote that in what I was writing
by the first copy of my Stop by the Cancer book,
I think back in 2010, and it was about Kibo
that killed him, not the tumors in his liver.
But what if you're doing all the natural alternative stuff,
diet supplements, right, and still get recurrence of tumors
in your liver?
So I think the question is, just because there's
bad stories about Kibo should everybody
avoid Kibo like the plague, and the answer is no.
Absolutely not.
Sometimes Kibo is the right thing to do.
It's the right thing to add to your protocol.
It's the right thing to help doubt the cancer.
If you're doing the right, you're doing other things
to help build up your body.
You can help prevent as much damage to your body
as you possibly can while taking Kibo.
Understand, it's probably a good chance.
Totally snow was not using the right machine,
and may have not been doing any natural things as well.
A lot of people in public view stick right, straight line
to standards of care because they're afraid of the backlash
that they get if they were doing anything alternative
because they're more concerned with the public's view
of them quite often, at least that's what it seems like.
So when you are doing a lot of natural alternative things,
if you do choose to do Kibo, there's
some other things that we want to do to protect you
as well with Kibo following the Kibo protocol.
And if you're in what you're doing, I think, already.
So you're not, you know, you're, it doesn't mean
you're going to have the same outcome as totally snowed.
So I would agree.